la pandémie de comédie 19 pouces
plusieurs enseignants à faire la classe
en plein air au delà des avantages
sanitaires et de santé physique certains
croient qu enseigner dehors comporte en
plus des vertus pédagogiques mais il
reste aux scientifiques à mesurer
ceci n'est pas une forêt c'est une salle
de classe
celle des maternelles de madame karine
[Musique]
escaut
ici pas de bureau pas de tableaux blancs
interactifs pas de murs
mais des arbres des animaux dollars
les parts et karine landry a adopté la
pédagogie nature ces élèves sont le plus
souvent possible d'or
[Musique]
c'est là que la magie tout ce que ça
apporte aux enfants le faut le vivre
pour le constater
avec la pandémie de kobe de 19 l'idée de
faire la classe à l'extérieur a gagné en
popularité
- les couloirs que de se voir cet
intérêt croissant pour l'école or limur
offre une occasion inédite d'étudier ses
impacts sur les élèves et leurs
enseignants
de quoi alimenter les chercheurs qui
s'intéressent à cette approche
pédagogique comme jean-philippe ayotte
beaudet donc cette année on a mené une
enquête auprès des personnes enseignante
puis on s'est rendu compte coûtant au
primaire et au secondaire qui avait une
augmentation importante des personnes
qui qui animait des activités
d'enseignement à l'extérieur et toute
cette expertise le quitte en train de se
développer autant sur le terrain au
niveau des personnes enseignante cas au
niveau de la recherche ça va aider a
vraiment donné un souffle à ces
pratiques l'appui a donné l'envi je
pense aux gens de continuer de le faire
ou du moins de savoir pourquoi ils le
font
l'intérêt de l'école d'orgue bien au
delà des questions sanitaires les élèves
pourraient en bénéficier sur le plan de
la santé physique et mentale mais aussi
des aptitudes sociales
il ne sera pas là
il y a deux ans l'école saint nom de
jésus à beaulac-garthby dans chaudière
appalaches a cherché une façon de se
réinventer la municipalité ici à
beaulac-garthby ils sont venus nous voir
avec le centre de santé pour nous
proposer de fonds des projets de
pédagogie par le plein air c'est la
naissance de l'idée
et puis ça le met tout le monde est
aujourd'hui au péché aux yeux des quais
c'est l'enseignant d'éducation physique
jérôme fortin qui coordonne les
activités sur le dos pour savez vous
comment ça c'était
au temps mauvais temps chaque groupe
passent au moins une après midi par
semaine avec lui en plein air à la pompe
ils font du vélo de la raquette du golf
du jardinage
ce jour là ils emmènent les petits de la
maternelle de karine landry à la pêche
je me suis entêtée championne total
at-on biais de la chaîne but à
l'objectif principal c'est de faire
bouger les élèves mais ce n'est pas tout
j'ai des élèves qui arrivent en début
d'année leur motricité globale et pas
formés sont faibles les muscles sont pas
ils pas les muscles assez forts ils
s'enferment dans leur propre pied puis
tranquille mal et apprennent vraiment
être plus fort d'avoir une meilleure
coordination
c'est que les enfants apprennent
tranquillement à connaître avoir une
meilleure conscience corporelle à mieux
mesurer le danger à mieux se faire
confiance ou si
on va voir les plus grands on vise plus
de collaboration de la prise de risque
socialisation donc on veut les
confronter à eux mêmes aux autres pour
faire en sorte que de résoudre des
problèmes
difficiles après seulement deux ans de
mesurer les effets du projet le
directeur observe une plus grande
motivation des élèves et des parents
l'avenir dira le reste est ce qu'on a
moins de gestes de violence parce qu'on
a moins de comportements perturbateurs
c'est impossible de l'affirmer
formellement on a fait l'hypothèse par
exemple on aimerait sow être capable de
le voir à long terme dans 4 and première
cohorte voix avoir fait six ans en plein
air à partir de ce moment là j'ai
l'impression qu'on va peut-être être
capable de mesurer des choses un peu
plus sérieusement qu'on le fait
c'est le genre de questions qui
intéressent le chercheur en éducation
j'enfilais paillote beaudet qui étudie
les pratiques pédagogiques à l'extérieur
ce conte à avoir c'est que les personnes
en science nous disent que les élèves à
l'extérieur ya moins d'enjeu de
comportement généralement parce que
justement ils peuvent bouger quand on
est à l'intérieur chaque titre on prend
une dimension beaucoup plus importante
mais quand les élèves sont répartis un
peu partout à l'extérieur on voit moins
les réprimander au niveau du bruit les
élèves qui ont besoin de mobiliser leurs
énergies vont pouvoir le faire plus
facilement
pour ces deux éléments à l'on n'est pas
du tout dans un apprentissage à
l'extérieur le chercheur donne un cours
universitaire à des enseignants qui
veulent se lancer dans la pédagogie en
plein air dont l'exploration du mieux ce
qui leur parle des circonstances dans
lesquelles ça peut être pertinent quel
est mon intention d'apprendre sa leçon
vous avez à faire de l'écriture en plein
hiver baisse est certain que vous êtes
tenus à l'intérieur donc c'est vraiment
tout ce champ de recherche l'eau qui est
en pleine ébullition pour voir dans quel
contexte plus favorable puis dans quel
contexte les moins mais c'est certain
qu'un des objectifs c'est que les élèves
apprennent des choses à l'école pour que
ça leur reste au delà de l'école à
partir de l'école on va remonter sur
pie-ix évidemment tout le monde ne pas
une forêt à portée de main pour
enseigner au grand air soyez ouverts à
ce que vous allez voir il ya peut-être
des choses que vous aviez pas vu à
vandaele annick enseigne à des élèves de
5e et 6e année d'une autre école saint
nom de jésus cette fois dans le quartier
hochelaga maisonneuve à montréal
c'est beaucoup de gestion d'aller dehors
avec des élèves là avec un groupe
surtout en ville il faut des parents
accompagnateurs il faut s'arrêter il ya
les rues et les vélos il ya des camions
malgré les défis que ça peut comporter
elle a senti le besoin avec la pandémie
de sortir sa classe de la salle de
classe en garde pas la tablette quand tu
traverses accord ce jour là le groupe un
projet artistique nous photographier
leur quartier un bassin de vie vous avez
vu la texture on a vu chemin faisant
l'enseignante et aigre quelques notions
d'histoire qui sait pas ce que c'était
avant donc vous avez les portes à
l'avant ici là où il y avait les camions
de pompiers qui sortait puis derrière
c'est là on mettait les lances à
incendie chaque sortie est une occasion
de faire des apprentissages concrets
pour voir où l'on remarqué ce matin
avant de partir dehors ce qu'on a revu
c'est tout le vocabulaire qu'on avait vu
en arts plastiques depuis le début de
l'année les lignes les lignes droites et
une brise et les formes les textures les
motifs donc on a revu tout ça puis quand
on marchait je les entendais réinvestir
le vocabulaire qu'on avait revu c'est ça
qu'on veut là vraiment qu'ils
réinvestissent fait c'est pas juste du
papier du crayon et la feuille on
l'oubli après c'est que c'est autour
d'eux ils vivent avec
il ya aussi tout un créneau de recherche
en lien avec comment les contextes
d'apprentissage peuvent aider à ce que
les élèves fassent des apprentissages
qu'ils vont être plus durable plus
perrin sa demande souvent plus de temps
les situations d'apprentissage à
l'extérieur mais est ce qu'on semble
voir c'est que au niveau de la rétention
de la durabilité mais sans y avoir des
effets intéressants ces photos sont
imprimées clémence
de retour en classe les élèves se plonge
dans leurs créations à partir des photos
qu'ils ont prises ils finiront par y
consacrer tout le reste de la journée
ouais mais je trouve que ces fonds c'est
aussi moi des études semblent aussi
montré que le fait de passer du temps
dehors peut avoir un effet positif sur
la concentration
quand on va à l'extérieur et qu'après on
revient en classe travail et ils étaient
dans leurs projets oui des fois ça
niaise un peu parce que c'est ça reste
des enfants un pic millions chassez le
naturel il revient au galop mais ils
sont dedans ils ont envie d'avancer puis
ce sont des pensées donc
là l'énervement physique il est plus là
on va y aller 3 par 3 y en a qui peuvent
aider un qui s'en sont plaints pour la
réussite éducative
après la pandémie présenté au printemps
le gouvernement du québec souhaite
augmenter les occasions de sortir dehors
pour le bien-être des élèves et du
personnel
la liberté d'apprendre en explorant en
expérimentant est aussi en bougeant bref
en s'amusant